what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with
invincible now here's the thing i am
trying my best to avoid spoilers in the
titles
i am absolutely doing the best that i
can to avoid spoilers granted
having spoilers is part of the super
clickbait title scheme but i'm avoiding
it for invincible because i don't want
to ruin anything for you guys uh so
this story does technically kick off
with sinclair a lot of you guys remember
him from the tv show where he was
basically
uh making killer robots out of people
the way it plays out in the comics is
almost identical to the way it plays out
in the show
it just happens at a different point in
time right like this point where where
all the robots show up and people are
being transformed all that kind of stuff
that was a plot thread that was kind of
being built on
over the course of the comics and the
time that omniman was on earth when like
the great big huge event happens and
like invincible learns that like these
guys are being turned into robots
that happens after omni man leap so
again just kind of a little bit of a
difference
between the show and the comics it
doesn't screw up the continuity because
one of the cool things about invincible
is you do have like the main story
and then you have like little smaller
plot thread stories that kind of go
kind of take place over the course of
the the comic itself right but what we
end up doing here you know once it's
sinclair's caught thrown in prison he's
met by uh
cecil right and cecil's kind of like
okay like if you accept our
our offer that we're going to give you
you will not go to jail right you won't
face any kind of
any charges you won't have a criminal
record or anything like that like you'll
work for us right so a lot of you guys
are kind of familiar with that already
but what you're not familiar with is
when we switch over to allen the alien
now here's the cool thing
allen alien is on the planet that's
referred to as telescria which is the
home of the coalition of planets we'll
talk a little bit more about them as we
kind of get further into the comic book
story but what you end up doing here
is picking up with thaddeus right now
thaddeus of course meets with alan
and then kind of has this conversation
with him about how alan's kind of
growing and becoming
stronger and again that's the nature of
the character of alan we talked about
that before
that the way his character was portrayed
is that initially he was like an
experiment an attempt to create a race
or to genetically modify a race that
would basically put them on par with the
viltrumites in terms of strength and
durability the issue with this is that
while allen was super strong there was
nothing to indicate he was on the same
level as the velcro mites but what we're
learning here is that as time progresses
specifically in the aftermath of a
battle
and when he heals that allen's strength
level right now is
close to that of a velcro mic if it's
not directly on par with the veltroid
now we're not really given an absolute
answer here
the explanation that we're given is that
they're actually doing more tests and
they're kind of exploring a little bit
more to see where he's at but by all
standards of measurement he's equal to
the velcromites and so while it's not
necessarily a full army
it is certainly a winning move the funny
thing about this is though the question
alan has
is how could you possibly know all this
information about the vulture mites were
you getting all this information from
and a lot of it's just kind of chalked
up to the fact that it's the coalition
of worlds right as a coalition of
planets they have just
information all over the place instead
what thaddeus reveals is that he's
actually a viltrumite right the thaddeus
was essentially the first of the
viltrumites to rebel against the empire
to turn against them and to defect now
there is a much more
significant story to thaddeus than what
we're given here but essentially he just
kind of establishes that he founded the
coalition of planets to defend the
universe against the evils of his own
people right to basically face off
against the vulture mites and to to
really kind of
slow them down as best you could and a
lot of that's rooted in the fact that
you realize given the strength of the
viltrumites you can't really kill them
per se or at least there was nobody else
in the universe that seemed to be
on the the same level and capabilities
as being able to kill
the viltrumites right they're just far
too strong and far too capable but for
the longest time
thaddeus thought he was the only person
that was really able to stand against
the filter mites outside of those
individuals who were executed right
because he wasn't the only one there
were individuals who rebelled along with
him but in the end they were all more or
less killed and so the question is was
there anybody else capable of doing that
and then alan the alien showed up with
the story of
invincible and that's when he realizes
even if omniman is kind of defected and
more or less taken up his role on a
different world in the end
both omniman and invincible can be
swayed to the side of the coalition of
worlds and essentially they can have a
few viltrumites on their side is it
enough to win the war well honestly
we'll have to wait until we get to the
velcromite war story in order to find
out but one of the cool things that goes
on here
is you get this cool moment when you
have amber talking to her friends now
one of the things we've kind of
discussed here is the relationship
between amber and mark has largely been
on the rocks mostly because of the fact
and really only because of the fact that
with mark being invincible and
effectively being a guy who's a
superhero and he's really
the first line of defense in protecting
the world from the various threats that
are there that there's not really a
whole lot of time for a relationship and
this really comes into fruition in the
fact that he's always blowing her off
right they're always out on dates and
stuff like that then he just gets up and
leaves in the middle of it all the
reality is
despite the role that mark plays and
while his role as a superhero
is in truth more important than the
relationship he has with amber she's
feeling that lack of importance and
unlike
debbie who of course marks mom and the
wife of omni man that amber can't really
cope with it right just one of these
things where she's just kind of like i
mean yeah like talking to her friends
like i'm in love with mark i care about
mark but the reality is she's been
spending time
with a friend of hers named gary now
gary is is a guy that she just kind of
throws away right she's like she's just
he's a guy that i know yeah he's funny
but like at the end of the day like i'm
in love with mark right i'm not gonna
cheat on mark i'm not stepping out on
him
you know just to kind of get with this
guy gary because you guys see twinkles
in my eyes and you guys have never met
mark and you guys don't really
understand why that kind of a thing but
the reality of this and this is what's
kind of ironic
is you have this kind of situation where
you kind of have to look at mark for
what he is
right you have to look at him for for
the role that he plays and the sense
that you know that when the two when
mark kind of shows up out of nowhere and
even when her friends are kind of
talking to her about that the reality is
you kind of always have to ask yourself
the question like what does this person
bring to my life that makes them
worthwhile and at the same time like
what would my life look like if
i didn't have them and it's an important
thing to understand with mark because of
the world that he plays and because of
the power he has
and his place in society the reality is
his life would not be
bad without amber right it's just kind
of one of these things where it's like
you look around it's like what would i
lose if i didn't have you i wouldn't
wouldn't lose anything so
i mean you can stay if you want to or go
if you want to in all honesty i don't
really care
and and that lack of concern i mean mark
does care about her but that lack of
concern which is really evidenced by the
fact that he just
takes off because he has some mission to
go on or something like that is enough
to kill the relationship the real
question to ask is
does it matter if it dies and that's
that's really the ultimate question
when it comes to any relationship that
you're in if this relationship dies
doesn't matter and if the answer to that
question is no well then that's only a
reflection of one of two things either
it means that you've more or less got
your life sorted out and relationships
are just not a necessity for you which
is perfectly fine there are people that
find a measure of happiness in their
life by just traveling around
and just doing things on their own or it
may be that you just don't need to be in
a relationship because you just don't
care about people so it really kind of
depends on the situation it's a little
more nuanced than that but it really
kind of depends on the situation but one
of the other big things that kind of
goes on here is we actually transition
to mars this is one of the big talking
points here one of the big moments which
was the sequence a lot of you guys
remember them just kind of these little
squid looking things with brains they
basically conquered mars or kind of
escaped and took over mars but we
basically had this situation where
in effect the secrets have more or less
kind of taken over everything right they
just sort of spread all throughout all
over the place and are kind of forcing
the martians to their will right now
there is a way in which this works
and the the whole idea behind the
sequence is pretty cool here but one of
the things that happens
is you basically switch over to the
martian himself now for those of you
guys who don't really recall this
the way it played out is the the
astronaut that you see who's basically
covered in the the sequence
that's actually russ livingston the guy
you see who initially was portraying
russ livingston
on earth that's the martian he's
basically a shape-shifter he calls
himself the shapesmith which is
a pretty cool name if i'm being honest
with you guys that's a pretty badass
name but the reality of this is he's
kind of
made a little bit of a home for himself
among the guardians of the globe right
and that's one of the funny things about
the guardians is they are they seem to
be far
less discerning than traditional
superhero teams if this was the justice
league they would be like dude we don't
know you
right it's not gonna let you on the team
like that's ridiculous now some of this
also has to do with the fact that the
guardians of the globe are
kind of desperate they need as much help
as they can get right because they're
kind of reforming you also get a cool
moment where like the immortal as mary
duplicate kind of a little bit of a side
plot that was going on as the two of
them were just kind of together for a
little while it pissed off rex splode
when he walked in and found duplicate
banging the immortal and it's like what
did you expect man right this guy is
like he's got experience
he's been around for a while you're like
an immature prick what did you think was
gonna happen man
but the cool thing is you kind of end up
having shaped smith who who's kind of
here
and everybody's sort of talking and then
ultimately he just sort of reveals
himself
to cecil right because cecil's basically
talking about how like long-range
sensors and things like that are
indicating that like a ship or some kind
of a vehicle
is headed straight for them and is
coming from mars now while that's going
on you actually have mark after his
conversation with amber who takes over
takes off to africa
meets with adam eve and then while the
two of them are kind of talking bam he
kisses her right so it's just like
he doesn't quite know how to interpret
that right like how do i interpret the
fact that i just basically
made out with like this smoking hot
redheaded girl who i basically kind of
like but
i'm not really willing to admit it and
so it's kind of cool to see that little
bit of a romance blossoming there kind
of coming off the heels
of mark's previous experience when he
was jumping through the future and
talking to these these various
iterations of eve but then you basically
have you know again kind of jumping back
to cecil and then shaped smith is just
kind of like okay so like i really need
to be honest with you guys
um i didn't get these powers that i have
from like an unauthorized nasa
experiment uh
basically i have these these powers
because everybody on my planet has them
i'm from mars and cecil's like what but
how can cecil be mad
cecil's probably the most inept
government official ever right cecil
sucks at his job
and i feel like a simple phone call
would have like confirmed this guy was
lying through his teeth you know like
cecil's terrible at his job he's awful
but nonetheless he's pissed because he's
like okay and i think more of it's like
he's pissing himself but nonetheless we
basically end up getting this
explanation from shape smith where he
talks about the nature of the sequence
and what he basically says is that at
some point along the line at least the
story that's been told year over year
among the martians especially for the
younger kids so they're kind of aware of
that history and legacy
is that you ended up having this race
that kind of crash-landed on mars
and that a massive war broke out that
lasted you know nearly a century
ultimately the martians came out on top
only for them to realize you know as the
battle sort of went on that the conflict
was not really with this alien race but
it was actually with the sequence but
the sequence themselves are really more
of just like you know these this kind of
hive mind but not really capable of
anything beyond just simple movements
and simple
chores and and you know different things
like that right simple tasks but when
they bond to a host
they're capable of so much more and
that's when they realize like the main
enemies the sequence like these aliens
these blue aliens that showed up they
were just the hosts for the sequence now
the desire is to expand themselves
across the universe and to conquer world
after world so
not that different from the viltrumites
just going about it by a different means
but because of the nature of the
martians the sequence couldn't bond to
them and so what the martians did in
turn is they actually used them as more
or less a slave force
the problem with this is that the powers
that be right the the
more or less government of the martian
group was actually going through and
experimenting on them performing these
heinous acts
experimenting on the sequence different
things like that which in turn the kind
of
rebels out there who had a sort of
disdain for this realize it would lead
to nothing but animosity because if the
sequence after all this experimentation
and all these kind of heinous
things that were done to them if they
successfully bonded themselves to a host
it would be revenge time and that's
exactly what happened the nasa mission
came to mars and anybody out there who
basically arrives on mars and is a
potential host for the sequence is
immediately executed hence the reason
why the
the astronauts were going to be killed
but ultimately what ended up happening
is the rebels realized that astronauts
were there and they basically forced her
or took russ
and exposed him to the sequence and then
in turn uh shaped smith took the place
of russ and then came back to earth
and the idea behind this is that the
secrets would basically allow
the rebels to kind of cast off the
government and the hoax is not
necessarily they would live in unity but
that the the sequence would realize what
the rebels had done and then in turn say
okay fine we'll spare your world and the
disorder move on that's not what's gonna
happen and in fact cecil's pissed he's
like wait a minute so you left an
american citizen to be attacked by
parasites
on mars like that's what you did here
really man
like that's that's that's your whole
thing okay like i'll deal with you later
i need to make some phone calls and so
ultimately you end up having mark and
adam eve who show up to the guardians of
the globe base of operations being
summoned there
by cecil and cecil was like okay so like
we're all basically gonna get together
right like we're gonna
like we're gonna go to mars the only
ones who are basically gonna stay behind
are gonna be rex flow duplicate and
shrinking ray which is kind of funny
because freaking ray's like man i get
sidelined but it's like look man i mean
all you can do is shrink right i mean
they'll find you anyway
right they'll seek you out i mean
there's not a whole lot you can do but
basically you get robot monster girl the
immortal bulletproof and black samson
who all end up going out there for this
mission right and of course
you end up having uh immortal and adam
eve who go there as well now while this
goes on
you have mark who leaves a message for
amber and is just being like
super super ambiguous right like you
know there's nothing i can do amber i
have to go amber
right there's there's you know they need
me and like ultimately she's pissed off
because she got a call
yet again from mark that like he's gonna
blow her off i mean the reality is
even if mark really is a superhero he's
kind of being a dick
and so ultimately amber does exactly
what you would expect in the most
predictable way ever
and she calls gary as quote unquote a
shoulder to cry on now let me tell you
something guys
any woman out there who's having
struggles with their boyfriend and then
calls up another guy and says like i
just need a shoulder to cry on
they're probably going to end up banging
that's just the way it goes right that's
just that's just the way it is
and so ultimately you end up having this
this kind of crazy thing where once
they're on their way to mars
the questions kind of asked like what
weapons do we have on this ship because
we are getting ready to fly towards like
a
like literally a giant spaceship that's
making its way to earth with the
intention of conquering it and it's like
dude this is a space shuttle man
this thing is literally the equivalent
of like a space version of a city bus
there's no weapons here man when was the
last time that you saw like
laser beams on the side of a city bus
although admittedly that'd be cool
as hell man like imagine if like kildoz
or had laser beams on it that would be
nuts nonetheless
like rockets get fired the ship blows up
kate saves everybody right like
literally just creates a force field and
saves everybody this is kind of a cool
moment but you also get a little realism
here one of the big questions you always
had to ask whenever like the green
lanterns were like okay guys we're gonna
fly to the other side of the known
universe let's all make our green
bubbles and just go there
is like what do they do for oxygen and
like literally
literally people in there are like we
can't breathe
we're running out of air so i love that
little bit of realism
that goes on there because it's like i
mean this is a great idea but like
we need air to breathe and there's no
air in space and we're running out of
air here so
uh we need to do something now of course
they end up getting aboard the ship but
as soon as they do you kind of have the
rebels who are in the engine room
trying to find some way to overcome this
whole situation now ultimately
one of the guys are just kind of like
hey i found a squid like they smash it
and it's like no they have a high
mind they're all gonna know you're here
now right like if you'd left it alone
it wouldn't have known but now that
you've done something they're all like
they're all gonna know and literally
they all just come pouring in
and so at that point there's a few
things that go on that i kind of want to
talk about here
the first is that back on earth you
ended up having this kind of
crazy lizard organization right just
these crazy guys they're more or less
modeled after the serpent society from
the captain america comics but they've
more or less taken control of like a
nuclear base with the intent of just
unleashing absolute hell and just kind
of showing that like they're
they're a force to be reckoned with and
so you end up having like those who are
left behind right so like the rex flow
duplicate shrinking ray who all
basically you know kind of jump into the
attack and take these guys out
duplicate is just totally obliterated
right like duplicates killed
and she's she's just like smashed and
ripped to pieces right like all the
versions of her
are just like ripped apart just killed
and so duplicates gone
right after that like rexplode gets shot
in the head he survives but he gets shot
in the head and it's just kind of like
damn right
now more or less the the days kind of
saved after that minus the death of
duplicate which you know i guess
maybe it's kind of you know crappy of me
to kind of skim over her death but i
mean you know come on
a girl that can make copies of herself
not the most impressive character ever
in the history of comic books
i'm just saying she's hardly relevant to
the story but nonetheless
as far as everybody else goes right back
in space that while adam eve is doing
everything she can to hold this force
field and you've got robot who
essentially
managed to find a way to temporarily
disrupt the hive mind of the
of the sequence it only lasted for a
minute or two and so what he's more or
less doing is trying to work on a way to
actually amplify it and to make it more
powerful so we can shut them all down
for quite some time right just
knock them out as opposed to just kind
of daze them and just kind of shock them
like man what was that right that kind
of a thing the problem is that adam eve
can't quite hold her power
in the way that she needs to in order to
keep everybody protected now this is
simply just the learning process right
this is one of the ways in which those
you guys are unfamiliar with comics
this is how you see characters grow
right that their powers are usually
pushed in extreme situations
whether it's agility or something like
that or in the case of adam eve trying
to hold up a
i guess a molecularly structured force
field as long as you possibly can her
powers just aren't quite on that level
yet to do it for
a lengthy meaningful amount of time and
so what you end up getting here is kind
of russ livingston
just kind of going nuts and rambling
about how like they can't be stopped you
know and they're ultra powerful and
they're going to conquer all of known
existence and someone you know so on and
so forth like you end up having immortal
who sort of jumps into the fray and
starts you know
literally going against this guy as best
he can as well as like all the different
secrets who were there
and then shaped smith has this genius
idea right where he's like okay
if we have to protect this guy then i'll
just cover everybody and that's what he
does he basically covers the covers
robot
literally as best he can because he
cannot be infected by the by the
sequence right he can't be turned he
can't be forced into one of their own
and so he literally just forms a giant
ball around this guy while
everybody else fights the secrets off
and then suddenly he hears robot
basically saying like i've done it i
fixed it and so initially immortal takes
it to go and use it but the biggest
problem immortal has
and it's one of the things that
invincible seems to hit up on his ego
seems to come into play that immortal is
an exceedingly proud character a lot of
it's because he sees himself as somebody
who's been around for a very long time
the guy who is the leader of the
guardians of the globe in his previous
form
therefore he should be the leader now
but the truth about this and mark makes
a good point he's like i'm faster than
you i'm stronger than you
this is too important for your ego to
get in the way the reality is that if
anybody should be doing this it should
be me
and so ultimately because of the fact
that that invincible can move faster
than the sequence can counter which
immortal doesn't seem to be on that
level he just runs up on russ livingston
and activates the beacon
and all the secrets get knocked out from
there he basically snatches up russ and
it's just kind of like okay cool we've
basically saved the day these guys are
knocked out there's no more hosts so
they're just going to go back to doing
you know uh regular meaningless tasks
according to you know the the martian
empire and that'll more or less be it
but the problem is the martians don't
want to let
shape smith go because at the end of the
day he more or less is the one that
caused all this right he's the reason
why
all this happened when he body swapped
with russ livingston and allowed russ
livingston to be taken over by the
sequence the problem is that they're
going to execute him and so what the
guardians are just like
no that ain't going to happen so they
basically snatch him up and just fly
into space as fast as they can
they take off as quick as they possibly
can now one of the other things that
kind of goes on here you kind of get a
little bit of follow-up to some of the
things that we've seen over the course
of the story so far
and so one of the first things that
happens here is you basically have mark
and everybody getting back to earth
and you have a little bit of a
discussion between adam even mark and
they don't really know
where this is going insofar as the fact
that they kissed do they have feelings
for each other mark isn't really sure
he's kind of like i don't know if i
really have
feelings for it all and even if he does
there's a few things he needs to resolve
and then he gets to amber's place and
gary's in there right like gary's in her
room
and and like he's overhearing this
conversation they're having where he's
like i mean you know it was it was a
good movie amber you know i had a great
time
you know and that's the thing she's like
well i mean it was cool but like i have
a boyfriend and then gary plays a smart
move right i hear about your boyfriend a
lot like where
where is he where exactly is your
boyfriend at and she's like well i don't
really know and he's like and where am i
and she's like you're here right like
you're right here now under normal
circumstances
that never would have worked right she
like she would she would have been like
man come on and like probably would have
kicked him out but giving the vulnerable
position that she's in
it works right like he's able to pull it
off gary read her like
a book and was just kind of like bam
right like like as soon as as soon as
like she says
like you're here and he touches her hand
boom he's in right like that door
it's not a foot in the door anymore
right that door is that door's blown
wide open blown off the hinges right
like i guess that guy is going to be
nailing amber in no time
and so so mark's just kind of like okay
right seeing this whole thing unfold he
actually does
really what he should do here right
which is going to her and saying look
like
it's over right like i mean there's no
reason for us to date anymore now he
kind of falls on a sword here which i
don't really agree with where he's kind
of like you know i mean
you know i really haven't been the best
boyfriend which is true he hasn't really
been about
been a great boyfriend or anything like
that but the reality is people date
according to their station in life
and the truth about this is that mark
dating amber that ain't gonna work
because amber just
it's she's not on mark's level right i
mean mark's literally a protector of the
world he's he's got all these
capabilities going for him adam eve
is a much better match for mark than
amber is right because adam eve
is on mark's level actually she's a
little higher than him because she's
more powerful than he is but nonetheless
right i mean like she
is she's more or less equal to him on a
societal level and so that's why that's
why it's gonna work right so that's why
like it's kind of like those two need to
be the ones who get together amber you
know ultimately when he tells her
everything that it's just kind of like i
mean it was cool when we first got
together and i first told you i was
invincible and then you were like yeah
i'm banging a superhero right like it
was kind of cool and everything
but now that we're really in the thick
of it right and we're kind of at that
point where it's like where's this
really going right you know ultimately
it's like i can't be the kind of
boyfriend that you need honestly because
i got more important things to worry
about
and so ultimately you know the like he
breaks up with her and she's kind of
like yeah i mean i was gonna break up
with you but i'm glad you did it first
you know so like ultimately they just
kind of stay friends and they go their
separate ways
and you kind of have this little bit of
a of a morning moment with the immortal
where he loses duplicate now this is a
big thing like after they've had the
whole funeral for duplicate with the
immortal it sucks right and this is
actually a great moment for his
character because the immortal's been
around for a long long time
and it's one of these things where he
and it almost kind of contrasts what's
going on with mark right in the sense
that with the immortal having this
conversation and just kind of like yeah
you know like it's nothing that i
haven't been through before
you know it's it's it's nothing that i'm
not used to at the end
it's just like you know she was she was
so young right and and i didn't know
that i'd lose her so soon and that's
kind of the crazy thing it's an
expectation
the immortal has lived for a pretty
lengthy amount of time and he's been in
love and he's lost them
oftentimes he's had to outlive them
different things like that but at the
end of the day
duplicate was young and and despite the
fact that he's been through this time
and time again he was genuinely in love
with her
and he was hoping that even though he
would ultimately outlive her presumably
at liver assuming that her power kept
her for didn't keep her from aging that
at the end of the day they'd have a
pretty
long and healthy life together likely
having kids different things like that
and then suddenly she was gone
not only was she gone he wasn't there he
wasn't there to protect her he wasn't
there to keep her safe
and so it's kind of a crazy situation
because it's like you know there's a lot
of regret there a lot of things that he
wish he'd done with regards to to
duplicate now the truth is they hadn't
been together for
all that long and so there wasn't really
a whole lot of time for
for him to have been able to do those
things in the first place so the reality
is it's more or less him just kind of
desiring
and mourning the future they could have
had as opposed to the time they had
which the future they could have had
could have been
could have been fantastic and so
following that you basically pick up
with russ livingston returning home and
his life is more or less going back to
normal to a degree
in the sense that he was offered his old
job back at nasa different things along
those lines after going through some
testing and so on and so forth he's kind
of able to turn back to return back to
normal but as soon as he gets home
he starts coughing like crazy and the
reason for this is he starts coughing up
sequence they literally
embedded themselves inside of his body
they bond themselves to to russ and
they're like it's only a matter of time
before we conquer the world
certainly the most courting corny ending
ever to a comic but amazing nonetheless
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
foreign
do
[Music]
you